ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meine lieben freunde allerdings
sehe der bereits es ist gar nicht meine
cd player welt sondern eine neue welt
und jetzt fragt ihr euch gleich einen
vollidioten auch hier mit dem staat ihr
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich luca was
sollen das warum ist das hier eine neue
welt wie das etwa neues projekt seien
beendet du deine minecraft serie auf
einer kleinen insel nein ich habe mir
einfach nur gedacht macht minecraft in
letzter zeit so viel spaß dabei
also ich habe zweifel dass nicht
irgendwo hinschmeißen kriegen perfekt
ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich luca was
sollen das ganze dann jetzt hier also
erstmal um alle gemüter zu beruhigen das
projekt minecraft mit luca auf meiner
insel wird natürlich selbstverständlich
weitergehen da kommt morgen eine neue
folge online die wir meine insel weiter
reparieren und eine neue portal insel
bauen werden wie angekündigt in der
letzten folge gestern allerdings wie
gerade bereits gesagt macht mit
minecraft extrem viel spaß momentan
weshalb ich mir gedacht habe luca du
könntest doch auch mal zwischen den
singleplayer let's play folgen sonntag
das ist mein ziel für 2022 dann ich habe
mir auf jeden fall gedacht mensch luca
du könntest doch auch so mal zwischen
den folgen so ein bisschen mods testen
plugins ausprobieren und wir haben da
hin und direkten dorf es geht weiter
runter
[Musik]
es geht jetzt wird sie soll
ja das ist halt leider sogar die
wahrheit weil auf meiner hand schweigen
perfekt alle genauso freundlich wie
meine single let's play in meiner welt
habe ich halt nur den ozean und dann
meine kleine inselchen aber sollen doch
habe ich hab ich noch nie gesehen sind
dass sie für begrifflichkeit was sind
blogger alles ist das okay rahmig oder
was also dass sie sind ja irgendwelche
banner und zwar ein braunes banner aber
das hier ist das akazienholz einfach
also ich bin hier wirklich komplett
perplex es soll allerdings nicht um den
entwendeten aktien stammen gehen sondern
was ist der räuber ist es ein anderer
villiger als normale village oh nee ich
kann ganz normal mit dem traden aber
warum sieht man so komisch aus stimmt
voll vergessen bruder ich würde
allerdings sagen wir konzentrieren uns
nicht auf dieses dorf hier vorne
beziehungsweise geh doch mal mein gott
ist das risiko noch nie gesehen ich will
mich eigentlich gar nicht so doll auf
dieses dorf hier konzentriert habe ich
will mich gar nicht mehr so riesig auf
dieses dorf hier konzentrieren denn ihr
seht bereits im titel eingeblendet wir
testen heute mal wieder eine minecraft
mod eigentlich müsste ich jetzt mein
altes intro abspielen aber das geht
leider nicht weil ich die rechte daran
nicht habe und alle meine alten videos
auch geklemmt worden und nicht daran
ihren es kein geld mehr verdienen
deswegen singe ich einfach den song
[Applaus]
und da wieder herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen mod vorstellung hier in
minecraft denn wie ihr seht es ja
bereits im titel eingeblendet meine
lieben freunde ich tue so als würde
gerade ist das video starten an die in
[Musik]
dieses dorf so das sieht aus wie
spongebobs ananas was geht denn hier ab
was ist denn das für ein geisteskranker
es dort vier vorne hall oku
[Musik]
ja das stimmt ich tu dir so die ganze
zeit dann wird das video gerade
losgegangen sein ich bin mir meiner
aufnahme allerdings schon mit einer
viertelstunde und wie ich habe noch gar
nicht über den mod geredet
beziehungsweise die modifikationen der
mutter ich weiß es nicht genau
auf jeden fall hätten wir heute eine
random blog mod vielleicht kennen das
schon einige aus den videos von dream
aus amerika und 2 geht es bei der random
blog mod darum das kann ich euch
eigentlich ganz gut zeigen
für gucke ich nur ganz kurz am liebsten
mal hoch so dass ich keinen block
anschauen jetzt geben wir einfach ein
random blog look leerzeichen start wie
die schon unten links random blog look
startet und ihr fragt euch luca wie
genau funktioniert das random brocken
look heißt es im blog
sie verändern sich ja
[Musik]
und verändert sich die glocke nicht
ich glaube es ändert sich nicht doch wir
können tatsächlich was ist das denn wie
sich das so das ach so wenig bürger
abbau okay dass dort jetzt ein bisschen
zu lang hier
wenn ich blocke aber so die blöcke
können sich auch verärgert wir können
die ganze zeit können wir hier nicht die
dann doch okay ich krieg die aber sogar
[Musik]
das ist ja mal fällig crazy selbst wenn
ich blocke abbauen werden die ersetzt
nie so weit geht es nicht ich kann aber
hier kann ich auf jeden fall noch hier
vorne kann ich auch selbstverständlich
ich guck mal da hinten rüber kann dahin
geht es nicht mehr aber hier zum
beispiel geht es wieder und ich kann
sogar blöcke öfters angucken dann seht
ihr schon verändern ihre dienste nicht
hilfreich lassen ja dass das ist auf
jeden fall die random blog modifikation
für minecraft jetzt habe ich mich ich
konnte ich kann ihr teilweise nicht mal
richtig drüber laufen weil ich die ganze
zeit von in welchem glocken aufgehalten
werde hier sind einfach im web stuhl
sich damit im internet surfen oder was
ich versuche jetzt einfach mal ganz
normal
minecraft zu spielen mit dieser mode
aktiviert dafür schmeiße ich erst mal
alle blöcke die ich vorhin bereits
gesammelt habe weg und wir tun so als
würde ich jetzt gerade erst neu geboren
sein und da herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einem neuen microsoft let's
play ich brauche als allererstes holz
das ist ja selbstverständlich logisch in
minecraft von daher erstmal ich komme
gar nicht zu dem holz hin
doch dass die kann ich abbauen aber das
kriege ich
ich glaube auch holz findet dass ich
wollte sagen ob holz findet dass keine
anwendung aber das hat ja auch geile
kiste er irgendwie hast du recht ich
nehme der verein akazien stamm
verwandelte den vier akazienholz bretter
und machen wir daraus eine werkbank die
märkte setzt jetzt erst mal hierhin und
wir
dass es schwieriger ist als gedacht wir
haben allerdings hier keinen neuen
holzblock
ich werde jetzt einfach mal den
dschungel reingehen vielleicht kommt die
mutter vor der 8 wir können uns den weg
ich kann das auf das ganze wasser
beziehen was geht denn jetzt ab ich kann
wird gerade ein wasser block durch ein
schwein ersetzt eine stunde später also
ich habe mich jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen umgeguckt hier und es sieht
alles total bunt und kunter warum es
salaam
ich wusste nicht dass auch lava dann da
hinkommen kann ich es ja so was von
verrückt da sieht man wirklich erst mal
wie es viele blöcke ist über die jahre
ins akh diamanten morgen kriege ich
jetzt irgendwie hin gebaut die abzubauen
ohne zu gucken ich kann einmal ganz kurz
in creative morgen game of creative und
mir zumindest schon mal eine spitzhacke
holen so dass sich die abbauen könnte
schrägstrich game of survival wir gehen
wieder zurück und jetzt wenn ich ganz
schnell bin ich hab's aber wie kriegt
denn jetzt ich habe dir halbes herz
alter schwede kräfte geil das aussieht
einfach alles trennende minecraft blöcke
man sieht auf jeden fall das spiel echt
ein bisschen ruckeln wenn ich hier
teilweise so hingucke aber kommerz
bringt der ganze dschungel ab
tschuldigung tut mir leid ich wollte nur
ganz kurz diesem minecraft motto auszeit
ist mit euch meine lieben freunde
mir wurde gesagt uk wenn ihr einfach so
viel spaß macht dann macht auch nicht
nur eine singleplayer let's play sondern
macht auch vielleicht auch zwischendurch
dann packte eine videos mal vielleicht
wieder auf den online server multiplayer
mäßig oder test in porz und so weiter
und so fort von daher wenn es euch
gefallen hat meine lieben freunde lasst
gerne einen daumen hoch oder dem video
hier da abonniert nur ein kanal für
kleinteile luxus sein und wenn ihr schon
aber nett trägt hier noch die glocke
damit ihr weitere videos nicht verpasst
morgen geht es weiter mit dem minecraft
singleplayer let's play und wenn ihr
weitere ideen habt für irgendwelche
kräfte mod reviews plugins et cetera
dann schreib rechen und in die
kommentare
wir sehen uns morgen wiederholen macht's
gut
[Musik]